last week. The last one was in September. After four months on the hormone blockers by tumors and
non-mass areas have shrunk about 50 percent, it seems. Consulting with the surgeon next week to get
her opinion on my next step options. The week after I've tentatively scheduled a consult with Dr. Simmons
to get her second opinion on surgery, along with what she would recommend post-surgery, as far as
treatment, I'm not likely to opt for radiation, and I know they will want me to keep,
want to keep me on some kind of horrible blockers. It's likely with all this feedback,
I will schedule a one I'm going to go to you, try to help figure out my program from there.
Yeah, I would, I'm not a big fan of radiation for breast cancer at all, because you're going through
the chest cavity, you're going through the heart, you're affecting major arteries, so I'm not a big
fan of radiation for breast cancer. The hormone blockers, if they're tolerable, just do work better than,
you know, the natural hormone blockers. So if you're able to tolerate it, and they want to keep you
on that, I wouldn't do too much of a pushback if you've seen this good, this much of a change. I mean,
that's a great, that's a 50% reduction, is something to be celebrated.